القوات الروسيه هجوما عليها
[موسيقى]
احد قاده الوحده العسكريه الاوكرانيه اعلن
ان الروس حاولوا اختراق الدفاعات في كل
الاتجاهات
الجيش الروسي متفوق عددا
انطلقت عزيزات في الاشهر الاخيره من
المئات من عناصر الاحتياط المدنيين اضافه
الى مدانين لمحاوله السيطره على سائر
اراضي منطقه دون باس الاوكرانيه
وفي مدينه محمود شرقا كثف الجيش الروسي
بدعم من مجموعه فاقنر العسكريه القتاله من
اجل السيطره على المدينه
ونشر الجيش الاوكراني لقطات مصوره بطائره
مسيره قال انها تظهر قصفا مدفعيا بالقرب
من بخموت على مواقع عسكريه روسيه في حين
اعلن مستشار الامن القومي الاوكراني
استعداد بلاده للاسوا
روسيا تستعد اليقصى تصعيد وتقوم
بالتدريبات عندما يتعلق الامر بهجوم من
اتجاهات مختلفه كما هو الحال الان لا
نستبعد اي سيناريو في الاسبوعين او ثلاثه
اسابيع المقبله من جهاتها اخار كيف لم
تسلم من هجوم صاروخي ادى الى سقوط مبنى
باكمله مما اثار الرعب بين السكان كنت على
وشك الذهاب للراحه عندما بدات الاغراض
تتطاير يمينا ويسارا طارت جميع النوافذ
ارتئينا انه علينا المغادره فالاجواء
بارده والامطار تهط بشكل متواصل
غايه ولم نسمع صوت الانذار ثم حدث انفجار
مروع لم ارى قط مركبات عسكريه
هنا من هذا المبنى السكني يقع في المركز
التاريخي لمدينه خاركيف اذ تمكن رجال
الانقاذ من دخوله واخراج العالقين منه